what are organs that are easily
replaceable which are not
like on the list of things that are hard
to replace and not
where would you put a number one
what would you put it like at the bottom
well i'd say the kidneys are you know
nothing's easy but kidneys are easiest
in a way
partly i mean maybe a big factor there
is that other people have two of them
and can give one to you so you don't
have to wait for people to die which is
the case with hearts and livers
sometimes you can take a part of a liver
from someone who's alive and the liver
does have this kind of
mythological ability to regenerate
itself um in the myth of promise
prometheus he's you know chained to a
rock and the bird eats his liver every
day and it grows back every day and
that's uh actually biologically accurate
not that you can completely get rid of
it and it'll appear again but when
pieces of it are removed or injured it
does regenerate itself pretty amazingly
um
so i'd say the kidneys the fact that
they're more around um also it's you
know the kidneys a smaller organ it's
often just you don't have to put a
transplanted kidney where the kidney
should be in the back of the abdomen you
can just kind of stuff it into the
pelvis there because it's a smaller
organ the liver it'd be hard because
it's huge
and i guess we just have the most
experience with kidney transplants
because they are the most common
and then the heart and the brain are
probably
quite difficult brain as far as i know
hasn't been successfully done the heart
is is done um
and uh
definitely i've evaluated a lot of
patients with a heart transplant it does
work pretty well the mechanical heart
substitutes are also advancing quite
rapidly these days for a failing heart
there's certain kinds of devices they
can surgically implant like when a
failing heart isn't able to push hard
enough you know that's the heart's job
is pushing blood with sufficient
pressure to create blood pressure
when it fails there are actually these
devices you can strap onto the heart to
help it pump harder those are rapidly
advancing many of those were not
available even 10 years ago when i was
uh got out of med school and now they're
commonly used so maybe heart transplant
won't be as necessary in the future if
those mechanical things do advance and
as i said the heart is basically a
mechanical pump so perhaps it would be
the easiest organ to replace with the
mechanical device
you